what's the difference between a sequence
in a series well a sequence is a list
and a list is separated by commas
whereas a series is a sum you're adding
up all the terms in that series that's
you're adding them so some but first
let's talk about the notation so each
one of these terms you could call n
equals 1 N equals 2 N equals 3 N equals
4 etc that tells you what turn that
you're on where as a sub 1 sub means
like subscript a sub 2 a sub 3 that
tells you the value of that particular
term so what we're going to do now is
we're going to figure out how do we find
out a specific term in this sequence
well first of all the question is is it
arithmetic or as a geometric now when we
talk about arithmetic sequences we're
talking about are we adding the same
thing each time to get to the next term
if it's geometric then we're multiplying
by the same thing each time to get to
the next term so here what are we doing
to get to the next term it looks like
we're adding to adding to adding to
adding to they call that D equals 2
that's the common difference so D for
difference like if you subtract 5 minus
3 you get 2 7 minus 5 you get 2 but say
we wanted to find out what this sixth
term is what we would do is we would
start at 3 and we would add 2 once twice
three times four times five times so why
do we add to 5 times how come not six
well because we were already at the
first term three okay so we only had to
add that difference not six times about
5 times and that's where our formula
comes from here for arithmetic sequences
you take the first term a sub one plus
the common difference okay here D which
is 2 times n minus 1 and is whatever
term you want so in this case we want to
term 6 that's 6 minus 1 which is 5 and
you got it so this would be a sub 6
equals 10 plus 3 which is 13 which we we
knew that but say you wanted to find
like a term that was maybe like the 20th
term well instead of having to add to
add 2 at 2 until you got to the 20th
term we could write a formula or a rule
to find that so let's go ahead and do
that so a sub n it
a sub 1 which is 3 plus and minus 1
times D D is our common difference let's
go ahead and simplify this by
distributing the 2 so we get 2 n minus 2
plus 3 and let's combine like terms so
2n plus 1 because negative 2 plus 3 and
so now we have a formula or a rule for
finding any term if we want to find that
20th term we're just going to put in 22
times 20 is 40 plus 1 is 41 and it takes
you right to that term now another way
to write these rules is instead of
writing an explicit formula formula it
takes you right to that particular term
you can write what it's called a
recursive formula and the recursive
formula looks something like this let me
spec and show you you start off with
telling the person what's the first term
in the sequence in this case it's 3 so a
sub 1 meaning the value of the first
term is 3 and then you give them a rule
or a formula for finding the next term
now there's a couple different ways to
do this one way to do it is to refer to
the previous term so a sub n minus 1
that means one term before the term that
you're on that term that you want to
find and then we're just going to add a
two so for example if we want to find
the sixth term a sub six we would go to
the six minus one which is the a sub
five term here the value of the fifth
term and we would just add two and we
got it now the other way I was telling
you that you could write this is instead
of saying a sub n you could say a sub n
plus one so that means you want to go to
the the next term the one after the nth
term and so then you would take a sub n
that's the value of the term that you're
on and you would add to either one of
these is a fine whichever one you prefer
now say for example you wanted to add up
all these terms will say up to the 20th
term how would you do that well let me
illustrate here say you wanted to add
all the numbers from one to a hundred
well that would take you a while right
but look at this pattern so if you take
one plus a hundred you get a hundred in
1/2 plus 99 you get a hundred and one
three plus 98 you get a hundred and one
how many hundred and ones do you think
that we could make
you know by adding the numbers from 1 to
100 well if you said 50 you're right
because you're pairing them up two at a
time right so what we have here is we
have there's 50 100 in once so if we
generalize now and write this as a
formula what we did is we took the
number of terms which was 100 divided by
2 because we're pairing them up two at a
time and then what we did is we took the
first term a sub 1 which is 1 plus the
nth term okay which is the last term
which is a hundred and that's how we got
our hundred and one so that's where this
formula is coming from right here it's
the number of terms divided by 2 times
the sum of the first term in the last
term
okay so ban just means the the nth term
of the last term so going back to this
problem over here if we wanted to add up
the sum of the first 40 terms ok S sub
40 we know that there's 40 terms ok
we're dividing that by 2 because we're
gonna pair them up two at a time and the
first term we said was three and the
40th term let's see what the 40th term
is we're going to put 40 in four here so
that's 2 times 40 which is 80 plus one
which is 81 and so now we have 20 times
84 let's see 10 times 84 is 840 so it's
840 double that's 1680 and that's the
sum of the first 40 terms let's take a
look at this sequence now we've got 5 15
45 135 dot dot dot what are we doing to
get from this term to this next term to
the next term to the next term what here
you can see we're actually multiplying
by 3 and this thing that we're
multiplying by each time this is called
the ratio so our four ratio and if
you're having trouble finding out what
that ratio is just take the number
divided by the one before it
same thing here 45 divided by the number
before it and you can see we're getting
3 3 3 3 now if it looks like you're
dividing remember division is really
like multiplying by the reciprocal so if
it looks like you were dividing by 2
that's like multiplying by 1/2 same
thing with the arithmetic ones if it
looks like you're subtracting it's
really like adding a negative number so
that's important to keep in mind so
arithmetic you're adding the same thing
geometric your mult
by the same quantity but now let's say
we wanted to get an idea about how to
find the value of this fifth term here
well you can see we're starting at five
and we're multiplying by three how many
times one two three four now notice that
we're on the fifth term but we only
multiply by three four times so that's
where our formula comes from what you do
is you start at the first term you
multiply by the ratio n minus one time
so that's the N minus one power so if we
were to write this as a rule or formula
it'd be a sub N equals a sub one times R
to the N minus one our first term we
said was five per ratio is 3 to the n
minus one power and that's your rule or
your formula now if you wanted to write
it in a recursive manner you would do
the same thing you would let the person
know what term you're starting at which
is 5 and then you'd give them a rule for
finding that next term next term next
term now recursive formulas are good for
computers you know computer can do all
these calculations quite quickly and you
can write it like this where you're
taking the N minus 1 term and you're
multiplying by 3 so if we wanted to find
the fifth term a sub 5 we're taking the
a sub 5 minus 1 which is the a sub 4th
term okay which is this 135 and then
we're multiplying by 3 now if you wanted
to find the 10th term you might not want
to keep multiplying by 3 you know a
bunch of time so you could just put in
10 for n and find the value of that
tenth term now let's talk about how do
we find the sum or switching from
sequences to series now how would I find
the sum let's just say the first 10
terms well of course we could write them
all out and then add them up but if it
was like 20 terms or 100 terms that
would take too long so let's go ahead
and figure out the sum of the first 10
terms we're going to be using this
formula right here and the first term we
know is 5 so that's a sub 1 we have 1
minus the ratio which is 3 to the 10th
power because we have 10 terms all
divided by 1 minus the ratio 1 minus 3
now when you work with this formula you
want to be careful
some students mistakenly will write 1
minus 3 oh that's negative 2 to the 10th
power but you want to follow the order
of operations you want to do the
exponents first
and then the subtraction okay sir with
me so let me go to the calculator on
this one and I'm just going to do it
here you can do it in steps if you want
so I'm going to do three to the tenth
first I'm going to do one minus that
answer I'm going to multiply by five and
then divide by negative two and that
comes out to one hundred forty-seven
thousand six hundred and twenty and
that's the sum of the first 10 terms now
notice how this is such a large number
and it's because every time you multiply
by three you know you're tripling
tripling tripling is growing
exponentially so that's why we're
getting into quite a large number quite
quickly now another type of geometric
series we want to look at are these ones
here where you have it an infinite
number of terms see the dot dot dot so
it continues on and on and on as opposed
to a finite set of terms so this is the
form we're going to use for finite this
is the formula use for infinite
geometric series but the important thing
here is is that when you multiply by
that ratio that ratio has to be in
between negative 1 and 1 so what happens
you can see it I'm multiplying by 1/2
that's 50 1/2 that's 25 12.5 what is
this number getting closer and closer to
zero so that means that it's converging
okay so it's approaching zero and we can
sum all those terms up now if we were
multiplying by two each time that would
be what we call divergent and it would
be going to gradually to infinity if we
try to add all those terms up of course
there would be an infinite sum so we
wouldn't be able to actually get an
exact you know value for that sum so
here what we're gonna do now is we're
gonna use our formula we're gonna say
the sum of an infinite geometric series
it's the first term which is 100 over 1
minus the ratio we're multiplying by 1/2
each time to get to the next term so
this comes out to your 100 divided by
1/2 which equals 200 remember when you
divide by a fraction it's like
multiplying by the reciprocal again
sometimes you know you may have a
problem where it looks like it's getting
smaller right but it might actually be
diverging like for example here's a
little trick sometimes that teachers
might put on your test it might be
something like this like 8 plus 6 plus 4
plus 2 and you might say oh it's getting
closer to zero but what
happens because this is arithmetic you
actually just flew right by zero alright
so you keep subtracting two and
eventually this is going to go to
negative infinity you can't actually
find that some it's going to go to
negative infinity right so it has to be
geometric and the ratio has to between
be between negative one and one for it
to converge and for you to find the sum
let's look at a couple more challenging
problems so write or rule for the
arithmetic sequence when you're given
the third term is seven and the fifth
term is 13 so how do we do something
like that well let's go over here to our
arithmetic explicit formula now let's
take this term here we know that the
value of the third term is seven so
we're gonna call this seven the first
term we don't actually know and the
third term okay that's N equals three 3
minus 1 is 2 and the difference we also
don't know let's take this term here the
fifth term is 13 so same thing the value
of that term is 13 the first term we
don't know but 5 which is the term that
we run 5 minus 1 is 4 times the
difference which we don't know so what
we have is a system of equations where
we have two variables and two equations
so we can solve for a 1 and D so what
we're going to do is let's go ahead and
subtract these equations we're gonna use
the elimination method so the a ones
would cancel out 7 minus 13 is negative
6 2 D minus 4 D is negative 2 D and if
we divide both sides by negative 2 you
can see that D is equal to positive 3
now if we put 3 back into either one of
these equations I'll just put it into
this top one here we have 7 equals a 1
plus 2 times 3 which is 6 and if we
subtract 6 from both sides you can see
that a 1 is equal to 1 so now if we put
it all back together we can write a rule
for this sequence we have a sub N equals
a sub 1 which is 1 plus and minus 1
times D which is 3 and then I like to
just kind of simplify this down a little
bit by distributing and combine like
terms we have 3n minus 2 equals a sub n
now you could test it out if you want
you can put 5 in for example 15 minus 2
that's 13 you could put 3 in 3 times 3
is 9 minus 2 is 7 you know
checks out and that's our formula for
our arithmetic sequence but for this one
it says write a rule for the geometric
sequence given two terms how would you
do that one well same thing we're going
to go to our geometric explicit formula
the value of the second term is six and
we don't know what the first term is and
we don't know what the ratio is but we
know that second term so two minus one
and is equal to two so this is one over
here we have 162 equals we don't know
the first term we don't know the ratio
but 5 minus 1 is 4 so now we have two
variables the first term and the ratio
and we have two equations we can solve
that system what I'm going to do here is
I'm going to divide both sides by R ok
so now you can see that a one equals six
divided by R we can put that in place of
a 1 in the second equation so we have
one sixty two equals six divided by r
times r to the fourth now this is really
like R to the fourth over one because
anything can be written as a fraction
and we can do some cross reducing one of
these R's
cancels with one of these R's leaving
our cubed if we divide both sides by six
let me go to the calculator on that one
that comes out to 27 equals R cubed you
take the cube root of both sides and you
can see we're getting our equals three
now if we put three back in to either
one of these equations I'm going to put
it over here we have six divided by
three equals a sub 1 a sub 1 equals 2 so
we have the first term in the ratio we
can write our our rule or our formula
for any term in the geometric sequence
and if you want to check it out you can
always say I'll plug in 2 for example 2
minus 1 is 1 3 to the first is 3 times 2
gives you 6 and same thing with the next
term let's take a look at this summation
notation so see this Greek letter Sigma
here it kind of looks like an e that
represents the sum and what you do is
you take this number here on the bottom
this is called the index and you would
put it in so if I put one in I get 3
times 1 is 3 plus 2 is 5 ok that's our
first term now if I put 2 in 3 times 2
is 6 plus 2 is
if I put three in that's 9 plus 2 is 11
plus dot dot dot you work your way from
1 all the way up to 10 you know in order
sequentially like that so if we put 10
and we get 30 plus 2 which is 32 and
what the Sigma represents again is the
sum or summation it's a series and we're
adding up all these terms but what you
can notice here is that see how are
adding three three three this is an
arithmetic series so to find the sum
we're going to go over here to our
arithmetic series formula we're gonna
take n which is a number of terms ten
divided by two the first term a sub one
is five plus the last term which is 32
and we get five times 37 which is 150
plus 35 is a hundred and eighty-five and
you've got the sum so this is kind of
like a compact condensed way of writing
a series let's look at number two so
same idea here you're going to start at
the bottom index your K in this case and
you're going to put two in for K 1/2 to
the second power is 1/4 times 2 is 1/2
say for example we put the next one in
three we get 1/2 cubed which is 1/8
times 2 which is 1/4 say we put in 4 we
get 1/2 to the fourth powers 1/16 times
2 is 18.8 until you get to the seventh
term okay so here what you can see is
that we're multiplying by 1/2 each time
and we can see that the first term is
1/2 and now all we have to do is figure
out how many terms are there from 2 to 7
now a lot of people mistakenly will look
at this top number and say oh you know
Mario it's 7 that's not quite right
because we didn't start at 1 we started
at 2 and another mistake students make
is they say well oh seven minus 2 is 5
but there's actually 6 terms here
because think about it if somebody says
how many numbers are there from 1 to 5 5
minus 1 is 4 but really you can see
there's 5 terms when you're counting the
first and the last when you subtract you
have to add one more so 7 minus 2 is 5
plus 1 more is 6 we have 6 terms we know
it's geometric is our multiplying by 1/2
so we're gonna use this formula right
here so the sum of these six terms the
first term we said was 1/2 the ratio
which is 1/2
there were six terms all divided by one
minus one half so let's go to the
calculator on this one and let's see
what we get so we have one minus okay
all divided by and I'm getting let's see
if I can convert that to a fraction here
for us it's 63 64 okay let's look at
number three now this one you can see
that it's an infinite okay some here we
have a sum of an infinite number of
terms here if we put three in we have
one-third cubed which is 127 times four
which is four twenty sevens if we put in
four we're gonna get 1 over 81 times
four which is 4 over 81 and dot dot now
what's interesting about this one is
it's an infinite okay number of terms
we're going to use this infinite
geometric sum formula but we want to
make sure that that ratio is in between
negative one and one right well you can
see that this looks very much like our
explicit formula here for geometric
sequences a 1 times R to the n minus 1
you can see that that ratio is one third
and you can test it out by writing a few
terms but now if we want to find that
some we say okay for over twenty-seven
divided by a 1 minus the ratio which is
one-third so we get 427 s over one minus
one-third which is two-thirds of course
when you divide by a fresh and it's like
multiplying by the reciprocal we can do
a little bit of cross reducing here
three goes in here once 3 goes in here
nine times so we're getting a sum of two
ninths so if you like my teaching style
and you want to learn more about
sequences in series I'm gonna put a play
out list right there going over more of
these types of problems I'll see you
over in those videos